My name is Jordan,
and I’m in the class of 2016.
I’m in Mission Hill After School Program...
one of the many opportunities at Harvard
to get involved and volunteer.
This program in particular
works with kids in the Boston area.
We tutor them and mentor them
and work with them on their homework.
We have a student driving the van.
We’re all together.
And it’s a great community.
[ Jordan ] After a week of studying
and hard work and everything...
it’s nice to get together with a group of other
students that are interested in volunteering...
and then to give back to the communities.
One of the things that I love about
being part of a tutoring program...
is that most of the time
my students end up tutoring me.
[ Girl ]
She’s smart. She helps us.
And she’s pretty, funny.
It really helped me transition
from being a varsity athlete...
to being involved in another way I could
give back to the Harvard community.
[ Young Woman ]
It means so much...
and it becomes a huge part of your life
and a huge part of who you are.
I’ve had a very wonderful first year here.